sono maura e senza girarci troppo
intorno sono qui per parlarvi di un
argomento scomodo di un argomento che
solitamente viene trattato in ambiti un
po diversi il tentativo invece è quello
di normalizzarlo questo argomento che
interessa tanto gli uomini quanto le
donne ma deve interessare soprattutto le
donne trattandosi di una caratteristica
che ci appartiene e che ci deve essere
in parte restituita è lo square thing lo
squirting e l'eiaculazione femminile
cos'è lo squirting law school team
dell'emissione di un liquido di una
sostanza simile per composizione diciamo
all'acqua e che all'analisi dei campioni
si è rivelata a contenere fruttosio
glucosio sali minerali una piccolissima
percentuale di psa e una piccolissima
percentuale di urea questo ha creato
immediatamente un equivoco per cui lo
squirting viene considerato per i più
lena diluita cosa vuol dire vuol dire
che una donna che si troverà ascoltare
il più delle volte vivrà questa
caratteristica con imbarazzo con disagio
con vergogna complice poi spesso il
partner o la partner che ne sa ancora
meno almeno questo è stato il mio caso
vivrà con disagio questa condizione lo
square thing è un dono lo sporting abita
le donne ed è necessario fare amicizia
con questo tono capirlo comprenderlo
personalmente io sono stata curata per
circa due anni per una incontinenza
nonostante io al primo episodio di
squirting avevo circa 38 anni dicessi ai
medici che mi avevano in cura che è
in realtà questa situazione questa
emissione di acqua durante il rapporto
sessuale o la masturbazione si
verificava e in concomitanza con uno
stato di piacere molto intenso non
necessariamente con l'orgasmo
nonostante in qualche maniera dicessi ai
medici che semplicemente non ridevo
tossivo e avevo delle perdite le
cosiddette gocce della risata i medici
per due anni hanno deciso che dovevo
essere curata perché in continente
cercando diciamo in rete ho trovato
altre testimonianze ho trovato altre
donne e ho cominciato a condurre una
ricerca a titolo personale
scoprendo che in realtà lo script in
gara qualcosa di completamente diverso
che nulla aveva a che fare con l'urina e
che addirittura nei testi d'ippocrate di
galeno di aristotele si parla di
squirting in tutta la letteratura
indiana la nanda randa il kamasutra
citano lo squirting viene chiamato soave
frutto dell'amore in alcuni testi e
galeno stesso quando parlerà dello
scripting affermerà che la donna che non
emette il seme
il rischio di provare dolore
ne parlerà ristò tele non facendo alcuna
distinzione tra sam e femminile seme
maschile
in realtà lo scripting quindi ab dai
testi e li abita fino al 1600 e dal 1600
che lo sporting scompare dai testi
facciamoci due domande 1600
controriforma il bisogno di rinsaldare
tutti quei valori in qualche maniera
cattolici legati alla chiesa che stava
di fatto perdendo potere quindi non si
poteva assolutamente parlare di scooter
thing di piacere di piacere al femminile
complice poi un altro evento che fu nel
1800 la possibilità di ingravidare una
cagna da parte di lazzaro spallanzani
con una siringa
questo semplice gesto cosa dimostrò che
il piacere non era funzionare alla
riproduzione quindi tutto quello che era
legato al piacere
legacy clitoride e squirting scompaiono
dai testi se non è funzionale alla
riproduzione è qualcosa che non è utile
in sostanza il piacere femminile venne
considerato di fatto non utile calocchi
il silenzio sia sullo sporting sia sulla
clitoride allora immaginate se per 400
anni quindi tenendo conto che il
silenzio sullo sporting cala intorno al
1600 lo scripting non abita più i testi
lo sporting non abita più il corpo ora
in realtà cerchiamo di capire bene di
cosa parliamo
avevo detto che lo sportive l'emissione
di una sostanza simile l'acqua in una
situazione di piacere intenso
lo square thing è stato analizzato
grazie a una serie di ricerche che sullo
sporting si sono compiute la ricerca
diciamo più importante è quella di zare
agi adesso in italia c'è una ricerca
dell'università tor vergata
i professori anni e titolare della
ricerca io sono uno dei campioni della
ricerca quindi il mio ascoltando è stato
analizzato
diciamo che l'equivoco che in qualche
maniera lega lo sporting all'urina è la
presenza di una quantità di cure a nello
squirting una quantità risibile rispetto
al urina perché lui è presente lo square
thing non viene emesso dalla vagina ma
dal canale uretrale per contaminazione
essendo il canale identico a quello
dell'urina lo scripting si contamina ciò
spiegherebbe la presenza di corea ma
anche la quantità inferiore rispetto
allo riina
ai signori uomini voglio dire in questo
momento semplicemente una riflessione
anche lo sperma attraversa il canale
uretrale ma nessuno si sognerebbe mai di
dire che sperma ed urina sono la stessa
cosa questo non vale per quanto riguarda
lo squirting altro elemento interessante
è il bisogno impellente di urinare in
una situazione di piacere molto intenso
a molte donne mi chiedo a quante di voi
in sala adesso andranno a memoria e si
ricorderanno è capitato di avvertire
questa sensazione cosa fa la donna nel
momento in cui avverte questa sensazione
entra in ritrazione il corpo si contrae
spesso sviluppa un automatismo per cui
neanche in grado di rendersi conto che
di fatto si sta contraendo non
rilasciando lo square thing ritenendo
che si tratti invece di urina ora
se la donna si rilassasse e
lasciasse andare tutto quello che in
qualche maniera potrebbe uscire avrebbe
ben poco a che fare in questo caso con
l'urina purtroppo siamo in tempi strani
quindi sentirete spesso questo suono che
non è il suono più augurabile ma che
accompagna questi nostri giorni ma noi
cerchiamo di andare avanti nel nella
scoperta del pianeta squirting perché il
bisogno di urinare il bisogno di urinare
deriva dal fatto che lo sporting viene
emesso da una ghiandola presumibilmente
una prostata femminile uso sempre il
termine presumibilmente perché sullo
scouting non c'è ricerca la ricerca è
molto difficoltosa in una situazione
intensa di piacere la prostata femminile
raddoppia il suo volume la prostata
femminile formata da una serie di
ghiandole che
sono diciamo vicino adiacenti alla
vescica
raddoppiando il volume anche il peso e
la compressione delle ghiandole sulla
vescica è maggiore questo ingenera il
falso la falsa convinzione di aver
bisogno di urinare
io dico sempre che si squarta con la
testa non con la [ __ ] questo termine
diciamo gentile per capire come lo
script in che sia qualcosa di molto
legato alla mente se la donna non si
rilassano squisita se il cervello non
dice non parla con la vagina e la
convince che quello che sta sentendo non
è il bisogno di urinare ma è il segnale
di squirting probabilmente certe cose
non accadono bisogna di fare amicizia
con le nostre basi né bisogna rifare
amicizia col nostro corpo strumenti come
lo yoga il massaggio tantrico sono
strumenti straordinari per imparare ad
abitare il corpo e per conoscerci perché
lo square thing ci abita ma dobbiamo
riconoscerne i segnali la presenza dello
sporting può essere precedente
concomitante o successiva l'orgasmo
quindi non deve necessariamente essere
contemporanea l'orgasmo
in ordine poi alla percentuale spesso mi
si chiede quante sono le donne che
scortano in realtà la percentuale in
occidente i medici diranno che è circa
il 10 per cento all'interno del 10 per
cento c'è una percentuale del 3 per
cento delle donne chiamate file fontana
in realtà le percentuali sono molte più
alte basta che facciamo un giro del
mondo e andiamo e ruanda e vedremo che
li il 90 per cento delle donne scorta
perché parliamo di coniata in ruanda il
cu nyanza è l'emissione di acqua durante
un rapporto
la donna che alcuni ato è considerata
fertile in questo caso però il curioso è
qualcosa che viene insegnato è un
patrimonio della cultura ronde se
insegnato alle giovani donne dalle nonne
o dalle zie paterne prendono le giovani
donne le portano fuori dal villaggio con
una scusa il cocoon a andare a
raccogliere le erbe per fare le scuole
scope realtà il gol è una pratica di
allungamento delle piccole labbra fino
ad avere questa dimensione per provare
più piacere per accedere a quella che
loro chiamano il kun ians del resto fa
parte della loro mitologia la regione
dei grandi laghi ed e terrana si ritiene
che lago kivu il lago più grande ed air
one da nasce da uno schizzo maestoso
della loro regina quindi fa parte della
loro cultura abita il loro corpo il 90
per cento delle donne allo squirting
donne sono in rwanda donne siamo noi
queste percentuali 10 per cento i 90 per
cento non parlano mettiamole in
comunicazioni mettiamo insieme tutti i
frammenti che compongono questo puzzle
meraviglioso di cui siamo fatti
ricordandoci soprattutto che non è
importante averlo non averlo perché non
è avere più o meno acqua durante un
rapporto sessuale a rendere più donna
una donna ma se abbiamo lo squirting
abbiamo il dovere di saperlo abbiamo
dovere di conoscere quelle che sono le
nostre potenzialità per cui lasciatevi
andare vivete il rapporto e vivete il
sesso con con felicità con leggerezza
che non è mai superficialità con
allegria e magari certe cose succedono e
succedono soprattutto quando la donna è
mentalmente rilassata per cui il mio
augurio è in qualche maniera di cercarvi
di trovarvi di accedere a questa forma
di piacere che straordinarie che fa
parte del femminile vi lascio con un
pensiero shakti in sanscrito vuol dire
potenza ma shakti linz ha scritto vuol
dire anche
donna donna e potenza hanno lo stesso
significato e il mio augurio in questo
caso è
fissate tutte